let's talk about Anthony scaramouche II
it's really really bad for brand new
White House communications director
Anthony scaramouche E to catch you up
Sean Spicer resigned over the hiring of
this guy he had a huge history of
anti-trump tweets and people found them
so scaramouche II went on his Twitter
account and started deleting them in a
panic as if you can't just find deleted
tweets on the internet are gone forever
it's like Tom thinks you fire someone
and no problems can come from that
scaramouche II thinks I'll just delete
tweets it's like they never happened and
then he gave a totally unintelligible
explanation as to why he was deleting
the tweets then he went on TV just hours
after being hired outed Donald Trump as
his source on some Russian hacking
assertions and we later found out that
trumps source on that same talking point
was actually Vladimir Putin so within
hours of being hired the director of
White House communications goes on
national corporate media and parrots
Kremlin talking points and now
scaramouche has put out a truly bizarre
tweet and then deleted it apparently
realizing it wasn't a good idea he
tweeted last night that he was going to
get in touch with federal officials
because of what he called a felonious
leak of his financial disclosure
tweeting in light of the leak of my
financial disclosure info which is a
felony I will be contacting the FBI and
the Justice Department hashtag swamp and
he tagged Reince Priebus there that's
part of it okay
then he deleted the tweet so a lot to
discuss here first of all what was he
referring to
scaramouche II was referring to a story
that was published by Politico which
reported that the new White House
communications director
scaramouche II is continuing to profit
from the sale of his hedge fund which is
called skybridge Capital now was there a
leak the forms that political references
are publicly available according to
Politico number two and this is where it
really starts to get completely bizarro
world
scaramouche E is accusing White House
chief of staff
Reince Priebus of something since he
included Priebus in that tweet and what
he's accusing him of seems to be that
previous himself might be the leaker at
the White House Caron
she has been trying to take this tough
attitude on leakers actually saying
something like if I have to fire
everyone in our department other than
myself and the new White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders to stop
the leaks I will do that that's what it
very clearly seemed that skerin Moochie
was doing by including Reince Priebus in
these tweets but he went on CNN this
morning and I guess kind of said that's
not what he was doing but then he
basically dared Reince Priebus to deny
being the leaker it's all very weird
take a listen to this I don't like the
activity that's going on in the White
House I don't like what they're doing to
my friend I don't like what they're
doing through the president United
States or their fellow colleagues in the
West Wing if you want to talk about the
staff we have had odds we have had
differences when I said we were brothers
from the on the podium that's because
we're rough up some brothers are like
Cain and Abel other brothers can fight
with each other and get along I don't
know if this is repairable or not that
will be up to the president but he's the
chief of staff he's responsible for
understanding and uncovering and helping
me do that inside the White House which
is why I put that tweet out last night
yeah when a journalist who actually know
who the leakers are like Ryan Lizza they
know the leaders Jonathan's plane a taxi
oh these guys know who the leakers are I
respect him for not telling me because I
understand and respect journalistic
integrity however when I put out a tweet
and I put writes his name in the tweet
they're all making the assumption that
it's him because journalists know who
the leakers are so if alliance wants to
explain that he's not a leaker let him
do that so basically he's saying yeah I
mean even if I'm not saying Ryan says
the leaker if people are saying that
that's what I'm saying it might be
because they know who it is and can
infer that I'm saying that that's who it
is because independently they know
that's who it is I mean it's a crazy
logic but then New Yorker reporter Ryan
Lizza who was mentioned there by Scarah
Moochie investigated and confirmed that
yes scaramouche she does want Reince
Priebus investigated tweeting in case
there's any ambiguity in his tweet I can
confirm that scaramouche she wants the
FBI to investigate rights for leaking
this is big trouble right I don't know
if this is repairable it's up to the
president blah blah blah scaramouche is
in Spicer is out is previous maybe out
and you've been saying for a while pat
that you believe Reince Priebus is one
of the top names on the chopping block
here to go next it's possible I mean
when you talk about scare emoji versus
previous I don't think Trump has any
loyalty to either one because you know
obviously the White House is in chaos
right now with all the scandals with all
the leaks and who do you blame for that
most likely your chief of staff which
Ryan's previous is and then scaramouche
E months or years ago said that Trump
was a hack politician yeah we had a
local Italian how can he be loyal to
either one of those guys Trump may not
even really understand how these
problems grow because he his lack of
understanding is how to make problems go
away
suggests to me he probably doesn't even
really understand how problems like
these develop and this is absurd public
infighting it's now between the Trump
White House director of communications
and the chief of staff you've got public
tension between the president and the
Attorney General between the president
and the acting FBI director between the
president and the special prosecutor
shmatte miss it was going to win it's
it's like we need a bracket really to
figure this out and our new poll at
david pakman.com asks exactly that
question which is who do you believe
will go next either through resignation
or firing from the Trump administration
you can vote at david pakman.com and
then next week we'll have the results
now we may also have an answer by next
week like by the time we even tell you
the results somebody may have already
been fired or resigned but we will see
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the
like an an eyeglass or the eyeglass
industry is controlled by very few
corporations that keep the prices very
very high even over $300 for
prescription glasses with Warby Parker
they started just 95 bucks mine cost
that including lenses and for every pair
sold they give a pair to someone in need
so to try the five pairs and support the
David Pakman show go to Warby Parker
trial comm /t DPS